Has my gut is in such bad shape? Do I continue to do coffee animals? Is there some other kind of
animal that I should consider how often? If coffee wasn't on your array 10, then yes, you could
continue to do coffee animals. Again, the purpose of the coffee animal is to stimulate your parasympathetics
to calm things down, to decrease inflammation, etc. Have you ever heard of using ozone suppositories
to heal the gut? Ozone suppositories can be beneficial if you have bacteria in the gut. So don't overthink
this. So you don't need to add this. You just need, you're complicated your life. You have enough
complications in trying to get rid of those food things and start adding some healing things.
Ozone is not going to be healing to the gut. Remember, Ozone is O3. It's oxidative and you don't want
more oxidative stress in the gut. The only time you would purposely add oxidative stress in the gut
is if you had colon cancer, or if you had a bacterial infection because oxidative stress will kill bacteria
can even kill some viruses, can kill other pathogens not as quite as well as single cell organisms.
And it can help tip over cancer. If you don't have cancer in the gut, and you don't have a bacterial
infection in the gut, and you add oxidative stress into the gut, well, then you're causing more
problems and you couldn't have more issues like causing cancer. So that's that balance between
oxidative stress and antioxidants that we've talked about a lot, and I have articles on the blog post
about that.